I have an exciting investment
opportunity only for two cents viewers
beard oil for dogs
I call it Grumio and it's a guaranteed
success how do I know trust me I just
feel it in my gut no serious investor
will trust their money to your gut and
you shouldn't either no matter how good
you think your idea is before you
mortgage your house or quit your day job
you owe it to yourself to thoroughly
investigate its market viability that is
a realistic data-driven prediction on
whether it can succeed in this
marketplace this applies to fortune 500
companies and handmade soap sellers on
Etsy one way or another the market will
judge your product wouldn't you rather
hear the verdict before you sink your
life savings into it Ruth here has been
giving her homemade artisanal soaps to
her friends and co-workers as gifts for
a while now and getting a lot of
positive feedback enough that she's
actually entertaining the idea of
starting a small business but before she
retires from her office job how can she
know whether there's truly a market for
this the answer is market research
marketing research companies generate
exhausted reports on pretty much any
industry you can think of including the
handmade global soap market they include
findings like market size growth rate
demographics industry leaders even how
facial scrubs perform versus liquid body
washes and it's all available to Ruth as
a downloadable PDF for $4,000 maybe Ruth
can afford that but I can't fortunately
there are plenty of cheaper options
I found this free report from the non
profit American Pet Products Association
which says that US spending on pet
products and services grew at an average
rate of about 5% annually comfortably
above the GDP average and that pet
ownership is increasing especially among
Millennials with dogs leading the
this is all good news for Grumio because
the bigger a market the more potential
customers and the faster it's growing
the more new customers who are much
easier to sell to then older customers
already stuck in their ways
the report also tells me that the
average dog owner spends 84 dollars a
year on grooming supplies and services
very useful info as I decide on a price
a major part of market research is
analyzing competitors if Ruth wants to
get into the homemade soap market she
needs to know what the successful brands
are how much they cost what are the most
popular ingredients and since she can
even request credit reports on these
companies for a fee unlike personal
credit score's business credit scores
are publicly available which will tell
her whether they're financially stable
and how much risk there is in the
industry
search engines and social media have
made collecting this type of information
easier than ever a simple google or
twitter search will often tell you who
the major players in an industry are
with a Google ad account you can see how
much competition there is for your
keywords and Google Trends is an easy
kind of fun way to find out what's hot
and what's not seriously you can burn a
lot of hours in here I can see that the
search terms dog grooming and beard oil
have both grown slightly over the last
five years I can tell what times of year
they're most on people's minds what
geographic regions they live in even
what related searches tend to overlap
this can all be useful when designing my
product and advertising strategy all of
this is considered a secondary market
research information that already exists
that you can purchase or find for free
but if you're really serious about
success you need to do primary market
research which means collecting data on
your own it's often more expensive and
time-consuming than secondary market
research but it always saves you money
in the long run because you narrow down
your audience and focus only on the
features that they're interested in
for example Martin wants to introduce a
new sandwich at his popular food truck a
double bacon BLT with garlic aioli and
truffle oil before will lick it out
he asks
his existing customers to fill out a
survey post some polls on his company's
social media accounts and just to be
really thorough pays a web service to
get survey responses from the types of
people who frequent food trucks low and
behold he finds that people who tend to
like bacon don't like truffle oil
because it's disgusting
he almost wasted a lot of money on an
expensive ingredient that would have
actually lowered sales thanks primary
market research many experienced market
researchers will tell you that when it
comes to collecting data
nothing beats face to face conversations
that's because customers are humans with
emotions and the most successful
products are ones that solve a pain
market pains or anything that causes
frustration or inconvenience in a
consumer it's a problem that your
product could potentially solve and the
best way to find it is talking directly
to people big companies conduct
interviews with lots of people of
marrying demographics and regions but
just because you can't afford that
doesn't mean you shouldn't talk to
people when you can but don't bother
asking your friends and family they're
likely to be nice and encouraging when
what you need is brutal honesty for
instance Ruth starts taking her handmade
soaps to the local farmers market and
make sure she strikes up a conversation
with anyone who will give her the time
she notices a trend in people who say
they wouldn't buy handmade soap online
because they're concerned about the
packaging waste aha market pain she
decides to make sure all her packaging
is made from recyclable materials and
that it's mentioned prominently in the
advertising for the truly introverted
entrepreneur the Internet does offer a
sneaky shortcut to finding market pain
the dreaded comment section if your
competitor has one you'll find people
happy to complain about drawbacks or
features they wish the product had
there's even a successful electronics
company that has made its whole business
model developing products based on
complaints in Amazon reviews I love this
nose hair trimmer but I wish it was
waterproofed BAM market paint this is a
very generalized overview of market
research there's a lot more to it
industry lifecycle market penetration
federal
regulation oh shoot I forgot to check if
animal cosmetics require FDA approval
and thankfully there are a lot of
resources out there the Small Business
Administration provides lists of
organizations that offer free market
reports and can help connect you with a
counselor or advisor but be careful of
business coaches who think their job is
to just be your cheerleader
while this encouragement is nice you
don't want to be encouraged off a cliff
oh the results of my survey are in the
percentage of dog owners who say they'd
be interested in Grumio is 4 percent
[Music]
maybe I shouldn't take out that loan
just yet and that's the most important
part of market research objective
honesty no matter how much you love your
idea if the research tells you otherwise
well that can be a good thing it means
you just saved yourself a lot of money
and effort and freed up your time to
develop an idea that will work and
that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description if you would like to
support us on patreon if you've ever
conducted market research share your
experience with us in the comments
you
[Music]